Hey everyone, Quincy Larson here with freeCodeCamp.
I am thrilled to introduce the 2021 Data Science curriculum expansion.
This is going to be massive. We've been working on it for several months.
This is actually something I've wanted to do for years. We're going to teach new certifications
in mathematics, data science, and machine learning.
And in order to teach these complicated, hierarchical topics, we're going to have to pull out all the stops
and roll out some really cool new learning experiences.
First of all, I want to remind everybody that we are raising money to be able to bring on some additional instructional staff
So that we can design these curricula.
There are a lot of topics that we ourselves have expertise on. For example
Beau has written an entire course for Manning that's focused on deep learning
so he knows a lot about neural networks and stuff like that. But we don't have as much
expertise in supervised learning or unsupervised learning. We don't have a lot of expertise
in teaching calculus or linear algebra so we're looking for some professors who do have experience
whom we can bring on to help design some of those projects.
So if you decide that you're willing to donate to our nonprofit...
If you're already donating $5 per month as one of the 7,000 people who support our nonprofit's mission
fantastic. You don't have to donate but if you do want to donate we would absolutely welcome it.
And the big news is Darrell Silver is matching all donations 100% up to $150,000.
So if you give $100 it's going to be like you gave $200. Because Darrell is going to give $100 as well to match that.
Of course freeCodeCamp is a donor-supported nonprofit, 501(c)(3), tax exempt.
Which menas that there's a good chance that you'll be able to deduct this from your taxes
depending on which country you're living in as well. And I can get you a donation receipt for that as well.
So be sure to make a donation to our nonprofit for this very special purpose of us helping build this new
curriculum. Now, I'm going to talk about the curriculum. There's quite a bit to cover
and there are going to be a few demos. So bear with me. First, what is the current curriculum? What does it look like?
Well, the curriculum represents the shortest path to getting a developer job. And here's our landing page.
Let's go to the curriculum section here.
And just because we can, let's switch it to night mode so it'll be a little easier on the eyes.
So, after this nice inspirational quote, we're going to see that the current curriculum is mostly web development.
We do have some Python development in here, but we're going to dramatically expand this.
So what is the new curriculum going to look like? Well, the first thing to note is that the curriculum
is a line. It's linear. We're not trying to introduce branching paths. I personally strongly believe that data science
is a natural progression after you've worked as a developer. You go back, you learn some additional math
you learn some additional skills and then you can become a data scientist. And if you really really
want to get into it, you can become a machine learning engineer. And you're going to learn even more math for that.
The logical hopping off points for being able to go out and get a web developer job – one of the full stack developer jobs out there
About half of all developer jobs are web development jobs. And if you're a full stack developer you should be able to do
pretty much anything. You may need to learn some new skills on the job, but this will give you a general framework.
Responsive web design, JavaScript algorithms and data structures, front end libraries
There's a new certification we're very proud of that we're going to demo in a few minutes where you're in VS Code and you're learning Bash and SQL and Postgres and Git
and lots of Linux commands interactively. Very cool. In VS Code. In a browser. On freeCodeCamp
So Tom's going to demo that in a minute. Then APIs and Microservices, Quality Assurance, Information Security.
All really important web development concepts.
Then if you want to stick around, or if you already have a web development job and you want to expand your skills
Data science. We use the Python ecosystem extensively. It's very powerful. You can do pretty much everything in Python that you need to do for data science
And it's growing very fast. There's this huge critical mass of talent that's contributing to the Python ecosystem.
So we're going to teach scientific computing with Python. Then we're going to get into teaching math.
And the way we're teaching math is with Jupyter Notebooks. Eric is going to demo what that looks like in just a moment.
But basically we've got tests that run within Jupyter Notebook, and you'll be able to basically learn math by coding.
You'll take a mathematical expresson and you'll implement that with code. Instead of the traditional way
You might write things out with pencil and paper and move things around – there's a lot of value in that too
But we're going to assume that people are busy adults and don't have time to go back to school and learn math
The way you would have learned it in primary or secondary school. They want to jump in and learn it
In the most practical and time-effective way, in a way that's integrated with the contemporary tools we have.
Nowadays unless you're out on a desert island, you probably have access to some kind of computer that may be very powerful
That you can use to do math. And so it's less about knowing how to do math by hand, and more about knowing how to use computers
to get whatever you need done. And that involves you understanding concepts. And we're going to teach you those concepts.
We're going to drill on those heavily through a series of tons of rigorous projects.
But the way you're going to learn math is a bit faster than going back and learning 12 years of math and then some university level math as well.
Instead, you're going to jump straight into it. But this will assume you haven't done math since high school.
And that you may not have even done that much math in high school.
That's how basic we're going to start here. We're going to do foundational math and then we're going to get into
Algorithmic problem solving. We'll take the math you've learned and apply it toward learning Greedy Algorithms, Divide and Conquer Algorithms,
Dynamic Programming. Things like that. Then we get into the real work horse of data science, which is statistics.
And here we're going to teach you in the descriptive statistics section all the statistics you can learn without knowing calculus.
And then we're going to turn around and apply that data engineering and exploratory data analysis.
With this, you're probably going to have the basic data science skills you need to be able to go to a small business or startup and start
gleaning insights from their data as a data scientist.
But if you want to work for a government or like a giant corporation that has tons of data. "Big data" as they used to call it. I don't know if they still call it that.
Lots of data, essentially. American Express level data or Visa level data or The IRS or something like that.
Those kinds of data sets. NASA or Cern Data? You're going to need a lot more than that. You're going to need to know calculus.
That's the first thing we're going to teach you in the advanced data science section. Single Variable calculus.
Then we're going to get into the advanced probability and statistics you can learn once you know calculus.
Then we're going to learn linear algebra and matrix algebra, which are very useful for doing machine learning.
And then of course, machine learning itself. We're going to cover all 3 big branches of machine learning.
Supervised learning, unsupervised learning, and reinforcement learning.
So if you're counting, that's like 19 certifications. Each of those takes about 300 hours. A conservative estimate.
In practice, we had one person who went through 6 different certifications. They speedran it. It was an experienced developer, Florin Pop.
He speedran the entire 6 certification in 29 days. That's about as fast you can probably do it. And this is 3 times that.
So you're going to be hard-pressed to get through this in even a few years.
Most likely you're going to be coming back to freeCodeCamp after you've been working, and you're going to continue to extend your skills.
And that's what learning's all about. It should be life-long learning. So you're going to be able to put this
life-long learning in action with a massive curriculum that will continue to help you grow as a developer.
So let's take a look at what the curriculum actually entails. Just to give you an idea of the level of specificity and atomacity
we've broken it down to. This is the web development curriculum. This is just a quick curriculum sheet. It shows you all the different topics
we're covering just for the responsive web development certification. We make it very granular.
We cover things in extreme detail because not only do we want to cover them but we want a lot of repetition
so that you're applying and then later you're re-applying, and you're building lots of different projects
to build your skills. And this sheet which I have link to by the way down in the description if you want to visit this yourself...
If you go over to for example the relational database certification, which you're going to see a demo of in a minute
We've got all the different bash commands that you're going to go through. A lot of them.
SQL, Postgres, yeah. You're going to learn all these different commands, all these different concepts. You're going to keep applying them over and over.
And another cool thing we're doing is we're taking these certification projects and instead of having all 5 of them at the end of the certification, we're going to have
level, level, boss battle. Level, level, boss battle. We're going to try to mix up the gameplay a little bit.
So you'll have hand-holdy tutorials where each step takes a minute or two to get through. Then you're going to have big
ambiguous challenges where it might take you a few hours to figure out how to build this project.
Both are very valuable.
And again, we've got all these different certifications mapped out with varying degrees of development.
For example, reinforcement learning. Markov chains, you're going to have a lot of fun with this.
So this is in the link below. At this point want to hand it over to Eric who's going to demo what the freeCodeCamp learning experience is like for mathematics
inside Jupyter notebook. Before I do that though, I just want to remind you. We are raising funds.
We budgeted about $300,000 to bring on some instructors to focus on this intently and it's probably going to take about 2 years.
So this is the budget for 2 years for bringing on a couple math instructors depending on how many of them are doing part time.
A lot of instructors work at a lot of different schools.
So we'd just like to build a really strong team of people who have expertise not just in these fields but in teaching these fields
to help us build out these curricula.
With that I'm going to hand it over to Eric. He's going to show us what the Jupyter Notebook experience looks like. Take it away, Eric.